if you're used to roadie running and
national roles gears tactics may seem a
bit unfamiliar and really tough
fortunately we here at GameSpot have
come up with a few essential tips and
strategies to help you rip apart the
Locust Horde with ease
number one not all cover is created
equal even if this is your first
tactical turn-based game you probably
know that your units should always be in
cover as you advance and flank your
enemies ensure that your soldiers are
safely tucked behind a lower high wall
before you end your turn keep in mind
that low and high walls have different
properties you can shoot over low cover
but you aren't fully protected from a
frontal attack high cover gives you full
frontal protection but you can only
target enemies at the corner of the wall
you should also be weary of destructible
wooden cover it breaks after one shot
and will knock your unit back think
carefully before you move your units one
bad move and you could lose one of your
favorite soldiers number two executions
executions executions every unit has a
set number of action points that dictate
how many actions that unit can carry out
each turn these actions include moving
firing throwing grenades and using
abilities however in Gears tactics each
time you get an execution each of your
squad members gets an extra action point
this means that as long as you keep
scoring executions you can prolong your
turn a few well-timed executions can
change the tide of battle in order to
get an execution first you need to down
an enemy to do that shoot until it drops
to its knees keep in mind that if you do
too much damage to an enemy it will die
right away
if you're near an enemy low on health to
switch to your pistol to ensure the down
number three overwatch if you're
familiar with XCOM then the term
overwatch should sound pretty familiar
basically it allows units to hold an
angle and shred an enemy that moves
within or into that units line-of-sight
overwatch is instrumental when it comes
to defense usually setting up overwatch
is the last thing you want to do in any
given turn because it will eat up all of
your units action points keep in mind
friendly fire is very much a thing in
Gears so we don't recommend setting up
overwatch directly behind another unit
if an enemy's overwatch is giving you a
hard time you can use the disabling shot
to stun them number four classes and
skill trees each unit both friendly and
low
he has a specific class called classes
come in the form of sniper support
Vanguard Paragon and heavy each class
has different abilities standard weapons
and a customizable skill tree we
recommend digging through each classes
skill trees to see how you want to
customize and develop your soldiers if
you don't like how one of your soldiers
turned out you can use respect tokens
which can be acquired throughout the
game number 5 locust classes
surprisingly traditional locust classes
and enemy types from Gears of War
translate pretty well to Gears tactics
drones are your common locust soldiers
they are fairly weak utilized range
attacks and love setting up overwatch
wretches can't take a lot of hits but
they will rush your units and claw them
because their movement is fairly
predictable overwatch can work wonders
or if you're near a group of them a
well-placed grenade can pop them like
water balloons the Grenadier is a
shirtless locust that carries a shotgun
and takes quite a few hits like wretches
they will rush you but if they manage to
pen a unit down they are much tougher to
deal with sniper drones are drones with
a lot more range if you can we recommend
taking out the snipers first these are
only a handful of enemy types you'll go
up against so pay extra attention
whenever a new one is introduced number
six loot boxes use tactics may not have
microtransactions but it still has
supply crates that contain weapon
attachments armor and cosmetics you can
earn crates by completing secondary
challenges or finding them on the
battlefield gray boxes house common loot
blue rare and purple legendary well we
do recommend going out of your way to
collect these crates be smart about when
you choose to do so rushing for these
crates can get you killed
number 7 side missions although gears
tactics is structured like your average
Gears game with acts and chapters
occasionally you will be able to embark
on side missions many of these side
quests compared with different gameplay
modifiers so be sure to check out your
mission Intel before you choose the
squad most of these missions are fairly
straightforward and offer decent rewards
but one thing to keep in mind is that
your units can only go on one side
mission per act this means that you may
want to think twice before setting out
on a mission stacked with only heroes if
you have any tips for use tactics please
leave them in the comments below and be
sure to check
our review here on YouTube or
gamespot.com thank you so much for
watching